[Musique]
pour être élu il faut une énergie folle
il faut une confiance folle il faut
foncer droit devant il faut partir à
fond et accélérer
tout président
au moment où accède à cette
responsabilité est enfermée
[Musique]
du calme il faut beaucoup de sang-froid
beaucoup douteux pour éviter de se
prendre un mur
mais il y a une très grande
contradiction dans la société française
nous voulons un président qui puisse
être au sommet
décider de notre destin commun et nous
le voulons accessible comment réussir
cette cette conjugaison c'est la
cinquième république mais qui est
Président fait partie de la famille des
gens qui vous aiment ou qui vous aiment
pas et donc il faut être prêt à payer le
prix
[Musique]
la question importante c'est de
comprendre à chaque instant jusqu'au on
peut aller la violence c'est le produit
finalement de ce que vous n'arrivez plus
à communiquer parce que vous n'avez plus
à exprimer c'est un peu comme le
dentifrice quand il sort du tube vous le
faites pas rentrer
[Musique]
une nouvelle manifestation organisée
pour protester contre la fermeture de la
Sorbonne 3000 CRS égards de mobiles
avaient pris place au Quartier Latin
l'escalade était engagé une semaine
impitoyable que manchette
je vais donc 13 ans j'habitais Rouen et
une ville plutôt calme bourgeoise
et
en avril tout paraissait tranquille et
on met je voyais mes propres enseignants
défilés dans la rue et dire que 10 ans
ça suffisait pour le général de Gaulle
de comment une société peut basculer
aussi rapidement c'est c'était ça mon
interrogation de préadolescent
[Musique]
alors pourquoi ce désordre
parce que le gouvernement était affaibli
par les élections préalables que les
syndicats étaient affaiblis par leur
manque d'autorité
et parce que
[Musique]
les jeunes n'acceptaient plus aucune
sorte d'autorité entendait avoir des
satisfactions qui revendiquaient
pas de mobile politique bien que les
leaders de la Fédération des étudiants
révolutionnaires se réclament volontiers
de Che Guevara
d'ailleurs c'était l'époque où les
jeunes bourgeois achetaient des
portraits de mozzettung et punissait ça
dans leur chambre
c'est une période de grande régression
intellectuelle il faut dire les choses
comme elles sont dans cette période là
il y avait une passion intellectuelle
c'était une période très très créative
irritante dangereuse et donc on avait
besoin aussi de parler et de s'exprimer
et donc au début c'est une
incompréhension totale c'est deux mondes
qui s'affrontent
[Applaudissements]
à 18h30 il y a 30 000 manifestants place
d'enfer Rochereau aux étudiants se sont
joints des lycéens
[Musique]
avec cette caractéristique de Gaulle et
Pompidou ont toujours été absents à un
moment ou à l'autre au début pendant les
10 premiers jours pour toujours été en
Afghanistan
quand il est rentré le 11 mai il a
trouvé un pays qui était à moitié
paralysé par la révolte étudiante il
faut appeler ça une révolte il a décidé
qu'il fallait réouvrir la Sorbonne je me
souviens que j'avais accompagné à la
télévision pour qu'il l'annonce j'ai
décidé
que la Sorbonne serait librement
rouvertes à partir de lundi l'attitude
de Pompidou était la suivante pour
l'instant
ce mouvement c'est sympathique parce que
les gens trouvent que tous ces jeunes il
faut bien les laisser un peu vivre et
qu'après tout ces voitures qui brûlent
ça peut être amusant
quand on s'est mis à brûleur propre
voiture ça les a beaucoup moins fait
rire
et puis quelques jours après ces deux
Gaules qui est parti en Roumanie pour un
certain nombre de
jours et qui est rentré qui a trouvé que
les autres c'était accru
pour parler clair les communistes
redoutant d'être dépassés par les
gauchistes dont il soupçonnait qu'ils
inspirent le mouvement étudiant ont
décidé d'entrer dans la grève
dans la rue
que je sois passé de l'université à ce
que on l'appelait encore la classe
ouvrière et qui était les masses elles
travailleurs ça c'était la surprise idée
le mardi voilà la France entière était
en grève et il est restée en grève
pendant jusqu'à la fin du mois
et c'était 10 millions de grévistes
c'était une grève très particulière
car personne n'avait plus l'autorité sur
personne
de la République s'adressera t-il
aujourd'hui à la nation je ne pense pas
n'est-ce pas mais si je puis vous
résumer l'opinion du Président de la
République c'est la réforme oui la
chiant oui non donc c'était un peu
l'état tout entier qui s'effondrait et
pour un homme qui avait tellement fait
pour la France tellement porté la France
se retrouver contestée par les jeunes
bourgeois
qui manifestait et qui ne comprenait
plus ça devait être un choc moral très
fort la tête de l'État et s'agissant
d'un homme qui avait véritablement fait
l'histoire
était plus révélateur qu'aucun autre sur
le fait que
génération politique s'efface et qu'une
nouvelle génération réclamait autre
chose il y a eu une grande manifestation
à Paris le 24 mai
[Musique]
et il y a eu des violences très grandes
à ce moment-là c'est la première fois
probablement qu'ils n'ont pas le
sentiment
de posséder la maîtrise des événements
[Musique]
françaises Français tout le monde
comprend évidemment
quelle est la portée des actuels
événements et très vite il s'est rendu
compte que
l'important c'était de redonner la
parole au peuple français oui j'ai
besoin que le peuple français dise qu'il
le veut il avait annoncé un référendum
c'était
un drame du point de vue de son image et
de l'efficacité politique 24 mai c'était
complètement à côté de la plaque que
pensez-vous de la locution du président
de la République moi j'ai pas été déçu
parce que je n'entendais pas grand chose
le discours n'a rien donné des
extraordinaires
j'estime qu'il a absolument rien dit de
sensationnel et surtout un discours pour
temporiser l'opinion et qu'on attendait
tout de même qui nous donne des
exercices mains sur la situation il doit
être pas mal embêté avec tous les
événements qui se produisent à l'heure
actuelle
et le Conseil des ministres devait se
réunir le mercredi
et le mercredi matin le général a
téléphoné au Premier ministre et lui a
dit je me sens fatigué j'ai besoin de me
reposer je vais partir pour colomber et
on reporte le Conseil des ministres à
demain
et puis il lui a dit je vous embrasse
un petit peu surpris
il a attribué j'imagine à l'émotion
cette
se dire congratulation qui n'était pas
ordinaire et puis
bon continuez à travailler et puis aux
environs de midi et demi-heure
il y a eu un bruit qui est arrivé et son
venus des collaborateurs du général et
puis le midi ces armées pour dire on a
perdu la trace que l'hélicoptère du
général mon père est alors
ministre des Finances
on apprend que de Gaulle
a disparu et
je vais finir je rentre dans son bureau
était très nerveux très
mais est-ce que tu es au courant et à ce
moment elle était au téléphone avec
Pompidou et me dire on sait pas où il
est voilà ça pourrait être l'accident ça
pouvait être en attente à ça
et c'est la rumeur s'est répandue je me
souviens d'ailleurs de ce moment-là très
précisément j'étais avec ma mère et
c'était le sentiment David qu'est-ce qui
va se passer général de Gaulle est parti
qu'est-ce que va devenir le pays c'était
l'incompréhension la stupéfaction et
d'ailleurs l'inquiétude le général de
Gaulle disparaissait c'était chef de
famille qui disparaissait mon père
racontait ça il y avait des gars qui
brûlaient des papiers dans des poils et
qui s'apprêtaient à fuir qu'est-ce que
vous faites au menant il dit c'est foutu
le général il est parti on sait plus les
manifestants vont prendre le pouvoir il
y a un coup d'état
c'est une ambiance révolutionnaire on
sait pas ce qui va se passer
[Musique]
et pendant deux heures on n'a pas su où
il était pour avoir une influence pour
être écoutée il faut se remettre au
milieu de la scène
avaient atterri à Baden de là à dire
qu'il a préparé son coup je ne sais pas
tu arrives au terrain d'hélicoptère à
peu près au moment où deux hélicoptères
se posent alors d'un des hélicoptères
sort le général et Madame De Gaulle
tout est foutu
les communistes ont tout en tout bloqué
alors j'ai fait son siège pour qu'il
s'en aille et je lui ai dit des choses
c'est dures on trouve qu'il avait pas le
droit de filer pas le droit de laisser
tomber j'ai senti que ce que je lui
disais lui faisait du bien parce que il
m'a dit continuer alors j'en ai j'en ai
un peu rajouté
il m'a dit
bon bah aller chercher ma femme
je repars
ensuite arriver à colomber un téléphone
au Premier ministre lui a dit bah voilà
je suis allé voir les militaires
et je saurai demain matin à l'Élysée on
tiendra le Conseil des ministres
l'après-midi et le général de Gaulle à
cette intuition absolument géniale
que il va pas parler à la télévision
est un communicant il sait quand il faut
parler avec son uniforme il sait quand
il faut parler en civil
à la radio
il s'est créé l'événement il a choisi de
parler à la radio comme quand il parlait
depuis Londres et alors on a mis la
radio
française français
étant le détenteur de la légitimité
nationale et République
j'ai examiné depuis 24 heures toutes les
solutions sans exception sans exception
dans les circonstances présentes je ne
me retirerai pas
j'ai un mandat du peuple je le remplirai
c'est un orateur qui a compris que pour
se faire comprendre c'est pas la peine
de perdre de long discours il fallait
quelques formules quelques phrases la
chanlie à Carteron de généraux en
retraite il avait ce génie de cette
phrase et bien non
la République n'appliquera pas le peuple
se ressaisira vive la République vive la
France
discours a duré j'ai vérifié moins de 4
minutes 30
il est arrivé au bout du discours
et la révolution était finie ce coût de
partir et de revenir
est un magnifique coup politique il
donnait le sentiment
d'être prêt à tout
et c'est ça qui a fait basculer
l'opinion publique qui a dit va bon
c'est un chef il est allé voir si
l'armée de soutenait
l'armée le soutiendra et donc maintenant
calmons-nous c'était une telle évidence
que je n'ai plus jamais oublié ce qui
était l'autorité politique ce qui était
la capacité de quelqu'un
en quelques phrases
de changer de changer le destin d'un
pays et le lendemain c'était l'immense
manifestation
[Musique]
ce point de vue la dramaturgie du
général de Gaulle a été assez efficace
où c'était un coup de mou
et même si c'était un coup de mousse qui
était sans doute la réalité le produit a
été celui de la dramaturgie mais vous
vous êtes jamais bien entendu je crois
poser la question pendant le général
Mathieu
j'avais demandé à ma mère l'autorisation
d'aller manifester aux Champs-Élysées
pour le général de Gaulle quand il a eu
la grande manifestation
j'ai tout de suite
intuitivement était portée vers la
famille gaulliste parce que je trouvais
qu'il y avait une affaire épique
c'était pour moi comme quand je lisais
Dumas ou Jules Verne on voyait les
choses en grand il y avait un lien avec
l'histoire
c'était l'histoire vivante et ça me
plaisait c'est ça qui a fait que je me
suis engagé
[Musique]
mais 68 démontre c'est pour ça que c'est
un échec malgré tout démontre que quand
il y a pas de débouchés politiques bah
finalement une révolution
trop de cours donc j'en ai gardé
finalement une certaine leçon moi-même
et il faut à tout prix éviter qu'un
mouvement ou dégénère ou se produisent
et se développe et il vaut mieux donc le
dialogue autant qu'il est possible
la négociation plutôt que
la violence et un moment la rupture dans
Paris déserté soudain de son tumulte la
civilisation de consommation prenait sa
revanche mais les Français et leur
gouvernement savent maintenant avec
quelle violence l'orage peut éclater
dans un ciel d'été
démocratie gouvernement du peuple par le
peuple pour le peuple si le peuple se
rebelle à part dans les pièces de
Berthol Brest on peut pas dissoudre le
peuple c'est une des belles choses de la
civilisation c'est un peuple civilisé ça
ne se manipule pas avec le court terme
[Musique]
183 début 84 à gauche au pouvoir veut
créer un grand service public de
l'éducation nationale bon c'est dans le
programme chacun pouvait choisir son
projet c'était donc la fin du service
public de l'éducation nationale et les
jours de gauche que je connaissais assez
bien n'était pas très content de l'issue
qu'avait trouvé sa varie c'est pas parce
qu'il y a une majorité qui arrive en 81
que vous pouvez balayer cette tradition
profonde qui est l'enseignement entre
guillemets religieux la religion
1905 la laïcité tout ça dès que vous
touchez un peu trop en profondeur vous
avez des des mouvements que vous ne
maîtrisez plus l'affaire était très mal
embarquée dans le Maine-et-Loire 40% des
enfants fréquentent l'école privée et
les organisations de parents d'élèves
avaient appelé à protester contre le
projet de loi Savary l'État doit remplir
son rôle
il tient compte des réalités
il reste sage dans la ménagement qu'il
fait des lois antérieures qui n'étaient
pas des lois de PET scolaire n'a pas
aperçu probablement le caractère
extrêmement choquant pour pour les gens
qui avaient leurs enfants dans les
écoles
y compris des hiérards socialistes quand
les objectifs ne sont pas clairs
évidemment toutes les oppositions se
coalisent et moi je vais participer à
une première manifestation à Poitiers
une deuxième manifestation énorme à
Bordeaux et troisième manifestation à
Paris où nous sommes venus mais par
milliers on avait des trains qui est de
Poitiers de Bordeaux de la musique des
chants des slogans en faveur de la
défense de l'enseignement privé
[Applaudissements]
organisateurs l'enseignement catholique
derrière des personnalités de
l'opposition madame weye Jean Lecanuet
Chaban-Delmas Michel Debré tous les élus
parisiens de l'opposition
c'était une de ses qualités ils
sentaient tout ça et même là même si on
ne sent pas les choses on les voyait un
moment il y a un million de gens dans la
rue 2 millions de manifestants selon les
organisateurs 560
000 selon un chiffre non définitif du
ministère de l'Intérieur
même Mitterrand est un habile et là tout
de suite compris et a compris que il
n'irait pas jusqu'au bout il faut
trouver une façon
de déplacer
ce projet de référendum
parce qu'il ouvre à notre peuple un
vaste espace de liberté
renforcera je le souhaite
l'unité nationale la perspective
d'un référendum sur le référendum
s'agissait détendre la possibilité de
faire le référendum aux questions
d'éducation François Mitterrand qui
s'est pris les pieds dans le tapis
l'annonce lui aussi d'un référendum sur
le référendum c'était
on voyait bien que c'était perdu qu'ils
étaient perdus
ça noyait les choses et
ça a permis de gagner un peu de temps
mais je vous le dis c'était des argusies
c'était donc
un jeune conseiller
j'étais pas compris pourquoi François
Mitterrand n'avait pas arrêté le
processus plutôt ça fait longtemps qu'il
pense que ce serait une impasse elle
arrivait
début 82 il y a un dîner Mitterrand
Hassan II il s'aimait pas énormément SN
de Giscard bon mais il se respectait
énormément en tant que d'État et Hassan
II connaissait par cœur la France
le fonctionnement de la politique
française depuis toujours
il dit à François Mitterrand monsieur le
Président je peux me mêler ce qui me
regarde pas mais je suis quand même
étonné cette histoire de projet sur
l'école
ça ressemble pas du tout à la France que
je connais mais je veux pas vous choquer
vous n'êtes pas obligé de répondre
mettons je veux bien vous répondre ma
figurez-vous que moi aussi
mais je ne pense pas que la France
puisse accepter la France telle qu'elle
est telle que je la connais son histoire
tout ça bon je crois pas que ce soit
acceptable finalement mais je n'ai pas
réussi en convaincre mes amis
socialistes
donc et puis ils sont tout à fait
sincères tout à fait convaincus c'est
important pour eux
je les laisse persévérer
et je crois que ça marchera pas à la fin
des fins
et quand ça sera bloqué je sais pas dans
quelles conditions mais un moment donné
ça passera pas je reprendrai la main oui
c'était pas une
dimension généreuse de François
Mitterrand c'était une dimension sans
doute éducatrice pédagogique François
mitter on voulait administrer une leçon
socialiste vous voulez cette réforme
allez-y vous voulez ne pas concéder
allez-y vous verrez ce qui va se passer
Alain Savary est sans doute aujourd'hui
très amère deux ans et demi de
négociation pour un texte retiré le
tempérament du personnage l'incite à ne
plus vouloir rester au gouvernement
malgré le match du président de la
République samedi dernier moi je pense
que c'est une bonne loi je pense que les
jugé de façon très injustes
pour Alain Savary qui était quelqu'un
qui appréciait et que tout le monde
appréciait à gauche évidemment quelque
chose d'épouvantable parce qu'il avait
défendu cette réforme
et puis qui a fait partir Pierre Mauroy
le Premier ministre monsieur Pierre
Mauroy a présenté au président de la
République la démission de son
gouvernement
le président de la République
François Mitterrand j'estimait ne pas un
pouvoir même lui premier secrétaire
devenu candidat devenu président et pas
pouvoir
convaincre les socialistes les amis
socialistes de d'arrêter ce projet mais
c'était à coup très élevé le coup élevé
sur le plan humain se séparer de Pierre
Mauroy a coulevé sur le plan politique
céder face à la pression d'une rue
bourgeoise sans doute mais d'une rue
donc voilà j'ai trouvé que c'était payé
cher le retrait le fond du sujet c'était
une réforme qui avait été mal définie
mal préparé et qui comme 17 notre
président a fait vous avez des projets
de de réforme qui sont qui échouent
parce qu'ils sont
intrinsèquement faux par rapport à ce
qu'elle a matrice politique de la France
Juppé c'est différent
monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
vous ai dit quel était l'ambition du
gouvernement
sauver notre système de protection
sociale
parce qu'il est notre meilleur arme pour
lutter contre l'exclusion et réduire la
fracture sociale ce projet réformes de
sécurité sociale ou des régimes spéciaux
il y avait des régions on peut pas dire
que c'était une erreur là il se trompe
sur la manière Jacques Chirac se fait
élire sur la position de Philippe Séguin
c'est à dire sur la fracture sociale et
même 10 égale le Munich social oui il y
a une fracture sociale forte et cette
fracture sociale s'appelle l'exclusion
en général celle de certains quartiers
je n'aime pas le terme de banlieue qui
vont à la dérive et une fois élu il
choisit l'autre orientation
l'orientation gestionnaire face à
l'orientation sociale après il y a
toujours ça vous passe simplement pour
Jacques Chirac il y a toujours un écart
entre le discours de campagne et la
réalité le socialisme était fatiguant
nous avait beaucoup affaibli et donc il
fallait créer un renouveau créé une
ambition donc
Juppé incarner tout ça
quand je suis arrivé à Matignon en 95
j'ai découvert une situation budgétaire
catastrophique et donc je me suis trouvé
confronté à cette situation où il
fallait un plan d'urgence pour arrêter
cette détérioration des comptes sociaux
et c'était une situation extrêmement
difficile qui m'a amené à prendre toute
une série de décisions à populaire dès
l'été augmentation des apports réduction
des dépenses et puis le trou de la Sécu
et puis pris par un enthousiasme
réformateur je me suis dit il va falloir
quand même s'attaquer aussi au régime
spéciaux de retraite le secrétariat
général de FO une école nota et quelques
autres
Chirac Bond
c'est peut-être pas le moment d'abord
cette réforme vous ne l'avez pas
vraiment étudié on n'a pas préparé des
textes contrairement à ce qu'on avait
fait sur l'assurance maladie donc n'en
parlez pas vous allez mettre le feu aux
poudres et le président reste un peu en
retrait
le Président vient d'être élu le
président
veille à garder une perspective et
garder et donc le premier est
globalement à ses seuls et dans mon
discours de novembre dont j'étais très
fier qui m'a valu d'ailleurs innovation
debout j'avais glissé cette phrase en
disant il va bien falloir ouvrir un jour
ou l'autre la question des régimes
spéciaux au nom de la justice nous
engagerons la réforme des régimes
spéciaux de retraite
il s'agira de préciser les mesures
nécessaires à l'équilibre de ces régimes
et notamment les modalités d'allongement
de 37 ans et demi à 40 ans de la durée
de cotisation requise pour bénéficier
d'une retraite à taux plein
ça a été la mèche l'allumette qui est
allumé la mèche
[Musique]
c'est trop tout ensemble et en plus non
seulement il faut faire les régions
spéciaux et la sécurité sociale mais en
plus c'est tellement mieux pas de débat
j'ai l'honneur d'engager devant vous la
responsabilité du gouvernement au titre
de l'article 49e de la Constitution sur
la déclaration que je viens de prononcer
sans avoir dès l'origine dès la campagne
et au-delà partager avec l'opinion les
raisons
impérieuse qui font qu'on est obligé de
faire ce qu'on fait et quand une réforme
de cette ampleur est proposée qu'elle
n'est pas véritablement partagée
concerté débattues et comprise et à ce
moment-là la rue peut se former c'était
Austerlitz en septembre
et ça a été Waterloo en décembre du coup
les manifestants et les grévistes
exigent davantage du Premier ministre
pas simplement des discussions sur les
retraites mais le retrait pur et simple
du plan de réforme de la Sécurité
sociale et c'est ça qui a provoqué la
mobilisation
qui a fait que les grèves ont été
douloureuses c'est-à-dire les transports
la SNCF etc je vais maintenant demander
pratiquement à tous les secteurs
d'activité progressivement de rentrer
dans la grève si j'étais forte ouvrière
même combat pour une même cause je
préfère une
fombreuse plus efficace c'était surtout
une certaine rigidité une fonction
publique qui fait de la mauvaise graisse
cette façon très rigide de ne pas
vouloir entendre la grève généralisée à
tous les secteurs des transports aux
hôpitaux en passant par les impôts etc
[Musique]
mais il y avait une forme peut-être que
Alain Juppé lui-même traduisait qui
était nous avons raison nous avons la
force légitime d'une Assemblée nationale
écrasante nous venons de sortir d'une
élection présidentielle et bien allons-y
et bien non il y a aussi d'autres règles
dans une démocratie c'est pas simplement
la démocratie politique il y a aussi une
démocratie sociale
de santé et puis la coordination
universitaire
des syndicats maîtrisés un processus y
compris pour bloquer le pays mais aussi
pour trouver une issue donc il y avait
des forces comme on dit des corps
intermédiaires qui pouvaient jouer par
exemple
aucun train ne circulera sur les lignes
de la peinture de Paris Saint-Lazare en
95 il y avait un phéno très important
qui est la sympathie de l'opinion
publique pour la manifestation certes
les gens qui vont prendre leur train ou
ce qu'il reste un autobus à pied et qui
font deux heures de marche trois heures
de marche pour leur travail sont pour
les rêves c'est un train qui viendra
probablement pas mais qu'on attend quand
même dans l'espoir de donc nous sommes
obligés de tenir compte de ça et alors
là il a fallu que
je pilote si je puis dire la marche
arrière voilà c'est toujours un peu
compliqué on peut pas tout critiquer
dans cette réforme Juppé notamment la
nécessité de maîtriser les dépenses
sociales devraient être pour nous aussi
un impératif c'est exactement le vase
rempli d'eau
vous mettez trois litres dedans et ça
déborde pas
puis tout d'un coup vous mettez une
goutte une pas deux une et ça déborde
bah c'est exactement ça le projet de
référend des retraites
[Musique]
en 95 j'ai cédé sur une partie de ce que
j'avais annoncé c'est à dire la réforme
des régimes spéciaux de retraite et pas
sur la réforme de l'assurance maladie
qui a été intégralement réalisé par les
ordonnances de 96 donc vous voyez on
pourra dire tout ce qu'on veut dans vos
sondages de Monsieur Juppé on ne peut
pas contester qu'il soit courage la
question n'est pas celle du courage on
dira il n'était pas courageux où il
était très courageeux absurde c'est une
question de connaissance de la France
jusqu'au on peut aller s'encas et
d'ailleurs les paroles savent avec leurs
enfants bonne question l'autorité
c'est une question de maintenir le
dialogue
parce que votre autorité si elle
consiste à ce que votre fils ou votre
fille refuse de vous parler elle va où
l'autorité et ben nulle part et c'est là
où c'est très difficile
il faut savoir reculer au bon moment
là il avait attendu le mois de décembre
pour reculer Jacques Chirac c'était
coûteux que le pays a été bloqué pendant
une année non ça durait les 15 premiers
jours de décembre donc voilà j'ai réagi
peut-être pas dans l'instant mais
j'allais pas tout de suite renoncer en
s'aidant en négocier
[Applaudissements]
j'ai créé quelque part que quand j'étais
brûlé un effigie notamment sur la place
de la Mairie de Bordeaux chaque fois que
j'allais dans ma ville je ne ressentais
aucune brûlure particulière mais enfin
bon j'ai un peu de forfanterie bien sûr
que ça ça bouscule ça ça préoccupe ça
angoisse même parfois mais enfin bon
quand on exerce ces fonctions il faut
avoir comme on dit il faut être droit
dans ses bottes pas mal l'émotion y en a
mais il est au moment de prendre la
décision pas après
c'est exactement vous êtes dans la
situation de Magellan qui traverse
l'Atlantique et après va traverser le
Pacifique Magellan cette idée folle il
veut aller vers l'est en partant vers
l'ouest bon
mais une fois que vous avez fait
l'Atlantique vous avez pas faire
demi-tour au moment de rentrer dans
Pacifique
une fois que j'avais décidé de faire la
réforme des retraites et que j'avais
fixé le curseur à 62 ans
tout retour en arrière était impossible
vous m'entendez impossible le
gouvernement dans la ligne de mire des
manifestants en quelques semaines et la
résignation ne semble pas atteindre les
cortèges pour le moment 9 jours 9 jours
de blocage complet
si vous commencez à trembler mais à ce
moment là ils vont marche dessus
parce qu'il sentent un peu vous savez
que ça branle dans le manche et qu'en
poussant on le fait casser ce n'est pas
une alternative possible d'où la
nécessité de débattre avant
[Musique]
le Premier ministre souhaitait plutôt 63
ans
la ministre des Finances avait même
évoqué 65 ans
c'est moi qui devait rendre l'arbitrage
c'est le président qui doit rendre
l'arbitrage j'ai dit ça sera 62 ans mais
tout de suite parce que je sentais que
ça passerait
mais je peux pas vous l'expliquer
autrement mis Michel cotta est-ce que
j'avais un raisonnement
avec petit un petit deux petits trois
non Michel Cottin pourquoi les autres
ont reculé je porte pas de jugement je
ne dis pas que c'était facile pour eux
je vous dis que j'ai appris de cela que
j'ai compris cela de
et que je ne voulais pas me trouver dans
le même situation il y a une discussion
entre monsieur Thibault et moi
j'ai des Thibault et un truc que vous
devez comprendre je ne céderai pas
pour la police la mobilisation est en
baisse les leaders syndicaux affichent
leur unité et dénonce l'inflexibilité du
gouvernement il est quand même
surprenant que dans un pays comme la
France après 6 manifestations on est
toujours pas de réponse c'est pas le
blocage total du pays qui est notre
objectif en soi ça peut être la
conséquence de l'intransigence du
gouvernement les syndicats le savaient
ils se sont dit quoi ok il reculera pas
on connaît
donc ils n'ont pas appuyé sur
accélérateur
on lui réglera son compte aux élections
131 pages de texte
4983 amendements déposés des dizaines de
milliers de manifestants dans les rues
derrière les sourires le bras de fer
commence assouplir la durée du temps de
travail faciliter les licenciements
économiques et plafonnés les indemnités
les mesures présentées brisent les
totems traditionnels de la gauche j'ai
toujours voulu qu'il y ait un dialogue
social et le partenaire qui s'était le
mieux
disposé à être dans dans le dialogue
était la CFDT dans la première
présentation de la
de la loi el khomri il y avait une
disposition qui heurtait la CFDT j'ai
donc très vite retirer cette disposition
pour permettre que le dialogue puisse se
reprendre avec la CFDT et des syndicats
réformistes et je n'ai pas cédé sur le
reste
les Nationales c'est l'effervescence
journaliste à
la pour baumomelle le chef de fil des
frondeurs nous avons tenu grâce au 49-3
une bonne entente entre le Président de
la République et moi-même et la ministre
du Travail Myriam el khomri qui a été
courageuse et la CFDT et c'est fort de
la conviction que notre économie a
besoin d'être soutenu au moment où elle
retrouve le chemin de la croissance
qu'il faut moderniser notre modèle
social le 49-3 était inévitable mais il
est apparu je pense que ça a marqué la
suite il est apparu comme comme un coup
de revolver ça m'arrive encore il y a
des gens qui dans la rue me disaient
49-3 à ce moment-là il a incarné une
forme de de violence je mets des
guillemets
anti-démocratiques alors c'est un outil
constitutionnel d'engager la
responsabilité du gouvernement et de mon
gouvernement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai jamais voulu utiliser le 49-3
jamais alors c'était plus facile pour
moi j'avais la majorité absolue mais je
n'ai jamais voulu
parce que si vous n'êtes pas capable
d'assumer le débat à l'Assemblée
nationale au Parlement vous l'avez dans
la rue
des incidents importants ont donc éclaté
dans plusieurs villes de France en marge
des manifestations contre la loi el
khomri
ils jettent tout ce qui leur tombe sous
la main pavé bouteille extincteur avec
des formes assez inattendues de
mobilisation c'est là qu'on a vu le rôle
des réseaux sociaux de cette capacité à
être présent partout les ministres se
déplaçaient ou même je pouvais aller
agiter des drapeaux à créer des
incidents donc des formes assez
nouvelles de de mobilisation et de
contestation
les quatre
choisis d'être toute mon attention quand
j'étais président
c'était d'éviter que les jeunes
descendent dans la rue c'est un souvenir
de mes 68 sûrement mais vraiment très
enfouie à ce moment-là c'est un souvenir
de maleykou cycine
très grave
jeune qui meurt les policiers en moto
surgissent selon le témoin 3 d'entre
descendes et le poursuivre
n'avait rien à voir en plus c'était
c'était pure exemple de brutalité
[Musique]
policière individuelle d'ailleurs
qui n'avait aucun sens il y a forcément
un basculement et d'ailleurs
reconnaissons-le tous les ministres de
l'Intérieur qui ont suivi ont été
marqués par ce drame là par la mort de
ce garçon les coups s'équines et avec
l'idée que cela ne se reproduise pas
c'était le souvenir aussi des mouvements
du CPE
et CIP avant sous Balladur c'est à dire
que quand vous avez des lycéens et des
étudiants qui descendent dans la rue
pour les faire revenir dans les
établissements c'est pas si simple on
peut arrêter un mouvement social en
négociant avec des syndicats de salariés
ou d'autres représentants c'est beaucoup
plus difficile avec un mouvement de
jeunesse donc il y a pas d'avenir sans
l'appui de la jeunesse donc la jeunesse
c'est un peu le socle de base de tout
projet politique et donc il n'y a pas de
projet politique pour un candidat si la
jeunesse contre lui et à partir du
moment où des réformes mettent les
jeunes dans la rue il faut chaque
gouvernement devrait penser que
ce sera un recul à la fin si ça
s'amplifie
[Musique]
retirer l'actuel projet de loi
le Premier ministre a décidé de
suspendre à partir d'aujourd'hui
l'application du contrat d'insertion
professionnelle
l'application du contrat premier
embauche j'ai voulu proposer une
solution forte cela n'a pas été compris
par tous
je le regrette
politique disent toujours c'est pas la
rue qui gouverne mais on a quand même
l'impression que sous la pression de la
rue les exécutifs sont extrêmement
fragiles oui mais mon cher ami négocié
ça veut dire reculer
si vous ne reculez pas vous négociez pas
il faut savoir ce qu'on veut quand même
négocier ça consiste à admettre qu'on
n'a pas nécessairement automatiquement
raison dans tout ce qu'on fait vous
croyez le général il n'a pas eu reculé
sur l'Algérie avec le nouveau
gouvernement algérien et puis il a pas
reculé avec les mineurs
on recule parfois et quand il le faut
quand on croit qu'il le faut
enfin il faut pas trop reculer quand
même
[Musique]
et puis qu'on arrête de nous prendre la
gorge parce que on en a ras-le-bol à
travers son
manque c'est un des mouvements les plus
significatifs qu'on est connu depuis un
demi siècle au départ ça ça se déclenche
sur la question du prix des carburants
et sur les limitations de vitesse sur
les routes nationales puis très vite ça
prend d'autres formes sur les salaires
ou sur les conditions de vie en général
qui dépasse la hausse du prix du
carburant
si j'entendais votre ras-le-bol et que
j'ai raconté de manière démago qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que je fais
je vous distribuerez de l'argent et je
me souviens de d'être allé de dialoguer
avec des gilets jaunes mais quel est
votre revendication et quelles sont vos
représentants répondaient nous avons une
idée ni revendication ah ça devient
difficile à ce moment-là mais ça ne
voulait pas dire qu'il n'y avait pas de
colère
justifiés quelquefois par le sentiment
d'abandon ou de mépris vous essayez de
discuter avec vous leur demandez mais
qu'est-ce que vous voulez ils savent pas
dire quoi parce que ce qu'ils veulent
c'est quelque chose qu'ils ont perdu en
quelque sorte c'est revenir à une
situation où
se fédérer autour de grandes entreprises
tout un ensemble d'activités qui
donnaient de la vie à la région je crois
très profondément que nous pouvons
transformer l'expression
pourront transformer les colères en
solution
quand on est devant un mouvement qui est
aussi
désincarné au sens où il n'est pas
conduit et aussi des politiciens d'une
certaine façon puisqu'il n'y a pas de
revendication c'est là qu'il y a un
danger de violence la violence c'est le
produit finalement de ce que vous
n'arrivez plus à communiquer parce que
vous avez plus à exprimer moi j'ai vu
trois énergumènes à la fin d'une
manifestation mettre le feu à une agence
bancaire est-ce que je n'avais jamais vu
ces 3000 personnes dans la rue qui
applaudissent quand les premières
flammes de l'agence sortent dans une rue
puis une autre d'un côté des gilets
jaunes déterminés qui multiplient les
barricades de feu de l'autre des CRS qui
avancent parfois à l'aveugle
et des blessés de part et d'autre la
violence fait partie de la vie surtout
en France
parce que vous pensez quoi la terreur
c'était pas violent
à la Libération il y a pas eu des
violences
la Commune de Paris c'était pas violent
nous sommes un pays où il y a de la
violence la rancœur
elle existe
parce que les Français sont des dingues
d'égalité
et que toutes les têtes qui dépassent
sont inacceptables et inacceptées
[Musique]
au fond quand on regarde les gilets
jaunes quand on regarde un certain temps
de choses on voit bien que la seule
réponse à la violence c'est la politique
encore faut-il que la politique soit
crédible en tant que la politique soit
reconnu légitime et donc on voit bien
que les gilets jaunes sont légitimes
parce que la politique n'est pas
légitime qu'évidemment l'exercice est
difficile pour rassembler et créer de
l'unité
[Applaudissements]
ne pensez pas une seule seconde que si
demain vous réussissez vos
investissements ou votre start-up
la chose est faite
non parce que vous aurez appris dans une
gare et une gare c'est un lieu où on
croise
les gens qui réussissent et les gens qui
ne sont rien alors après on peut dire
bah oui le président de la République
n'aurait pas dû s'exprimer ainsi soit et
que veut-on un président de la
République qui fasse de la langue de
bois le président de la République qui
ne disent jamais ce qu'il ressent ce
qu'il pense
on devient malheureux est-ce que vous
voulez m'écouter oui j'ai envie de vous
écouter mais là pourquoi on a fait ça
sur la CSG pourquoi on l'a fait c'est
l'engagement que j'avais pris en
campagne
enfermé dans ces certitudes dans son
côté donneur de leçon comprenez pas et
donc il ne mesurait pas
l'incidence parce que parfois vous êtes
en colère sur des trucs qui sont pas
vrai on fait tout est vrai vous sentez
pas de malaise en France qui mange
si je veux apporter une vraie attention
obligé de changer les choses vous n'êtes
pas connu mais vous répondre
la fracture majeure de la société
française aujourd'hui et donc
l'affaiblissement principal de notre
pays c'est la rupture entre le haut et
le bas de la pyramide sociale
entre les gouvernants ou qui se
prétendent tel
cette petite pointe de la pyramide et
puis la base
qui ne reconnaît plus ni la légitimité
ni les raisons d'agir
et qui ne trouvent plus de raison de
vivre dans cette organisation là on a vu
avec le président Sarkozy puis le
président Hollande puis le président
Macron il y a eu une forme de
détestation personnalisée
et au soudain c'est c'est le président
de la République qui devient saint
Sébastien criblé de flèches et donc ça
s'exprime avec plus ou moins de vigueur
c'est lié à l'époque de l'information
continue permanente aux réseaux sociaux
et je vois pas quelle personnalité
géante de l'histoire de France
serait intacte après trois mois de
réseau sociaux contemporains le Fouquet
célèbre restaurant de l'avenue n'a pas
non plus été épargné la journée avez
pourtant débuté dans le calme ailleurs
dans Paris ensuite la réaction du
printemps est très bien elle est au
contact et le Président nous explique
que il va organiser le grand débat une
son idée était de dire il faut que
j'aille dans l'arène dans les
territoires le plus souvent possible
expliqué ce qu'on fait répondre aux
questions etc un peu comme s'il
souhaitait aller à la recherche du temps
perdu
de ne pas avoir
peut-être suffisamment été alerté ou de
ne pas avoir suffisamment senti ce qui
se produisait la première façon d'agir
en politique c'est de parler
il n'y a pas d'un côté l'édition que
vous prenez et d'autres les mots que
vous prononcez les mots font partie de
l'action
le lien entre l'État que vous
représentez la nation que nous sommes
aujourd'hui rompus on a des territoires
où les patients décèdent par manque de
soins arrêtaient de changer les lois
tout le temps quand est-ce qu'on arrête
la machine à broyer la proximité si vous
faites un exercice comme celui qui a
fait le président de la République après
les gilets jaunes vous obtenez quoi un
cahier de doléances
mais vous n'obtenez pas des solutions
faut pas raconter des cracks c'est pas
parce qu'on remettra l'ISF comme il
était il y a un an et demi que la
situation d'un seul gilet jaune
s'améliorera ça c'est de la pipe ce que
je sais c'est que si je le faisais
demain les quelques-uns qui étaient en
train de revenir de créer de l'emploi il
dirait basculer on a compris il est
comme les autres et là ce talent de
l'expression de la communication de la
proximité de la connaissance de ces
dossiers et je pense que le grand débat
était une bonne idée mais au fond peu de
gens sont capables de le faire en ce 18e
samedi de manifestation avec la fin du
grand débat national les gilets jaunes
ont baptisé cette journée l'ultimatum
[Musique]
ça a marché parce que les gens ont vu
que c'était vrai c'est lui tout seul
dans le caractère direct de l'échange y
compris dans les échanges les plus dur
qui a montré non pas la véracité d'une
thèse mais quel homme il était capable
de le faire ce qui est assez
brillantissime mais au fond ça
l'installe aussi dans un statut je
dirais un peu
d'artistes de héros capable de faire des
exercices solitaires brillantes ici or
un chef c'est pas un solitaire la
politique
c'est d'abord une affaire d'incarnation
avant même d'être une idée
donnez-moi les pinceaux de Van Gogh
les toiles de Van Gogh
les tubes de peinture de Van Gogh
d'après vous ferez du Van Gogh non
redonner une espérance de progrès à
chacun
en demandant à chacun le meilleur de
lui-même
et c'est ainsi que nous pourrons
reconstruire ensemble très profondément
ce que j'appellerai
l'art d'être français
les paléofficiels vous mettent à l'écart
pour les responsables d'État il faut
sentir il faut regarder capteurs il
faudra l'expérience il y a des capteurs
qui sont officiels les ce qu'on appelait
autrefois les notes des préfets il y a
des capteurs qui sont politiques ce que
vous ramène normalement un parti ou des
parlementaires et puis il y a des
capteurs que vous pouvez avoir par votre
propre vie politique des gens auxquels
vous faites confiance parce que ils
étaient dans votre circonscription dans
votre ville ou des amis ou des leaders
syndicaux des responsables associés pour
des chefs d'entreprise qu'est-ce qui se
passe qu'est-ce qui se passe dans une
société qui est celle que vous avez en
charge
[Musique]